PROFESSOR: So what I want to
do in today's lecture is to
move us on to a topic not
unrelated to the one that we
were addressing before
March break.
So as you recall, what we were
thinking about before March
break were the relations that
people bear to one another as
far as moral responsibility
goes.
You might think the first part
of the course, the part on
flourishing, was about human
beings as individuals and the
ways in which, within
themselves, they might achieve
a certain kind of harmony.
The second part of the course
was about morality, about
interpersonal relations
between individuals.
And the third part of the
course, which we'll move to in
earnest next week, is about how
political structures might
play a role in cultivating
certain kinds of behavior on
the part of individuals.
Obviously, that's
an idealization.
Individuals considered in
isolation are always in
interaction with others.
Individuals in pairwise
relations are always embedded
within larger communities.
But the arc of the course has
been to move from individuals,
to small groups of individuals,
to larger groups
of individuals.
And the punishment unit, which
is just two lectures long, is
in some ways a transitional
unit between the morality
section and the political
philosophy section.
So what I want to do in our
running start, to get people
back thinking about the
questions that we've been
thinking about, is
to start with a
couple of clicker questions.
So I hope that your clickers
didn't get
lost over March break.
And to begin by asking you to
think about a couple of cases
in real life, tragically, that
have the structure that
Trolley problems do.
And then we'll move on to some
cases more directly related to
punishment.
So you remember that we devoted
a reasonable amount of
class attention to thinking
about an abstract and
idealized moral dilemma
situation, which is sometimes
called the Trolley
Bystander case.
There's a trolley which is about
to run into five people.
There's a bystander next to it,
who realizes that there's
an alternative track on which
only one person is standing.
And that bystander faces the
choice of whether to divert
the threat, the trolley, from
the track where there are the
five to the track where
there are the one.
Tragically, the world has found
itself with something
like an actual trolley case, in
the form of the effusion of
radioactive clouds from the
Japanese nuclear power plant.
So suppose you were--
this is the first clicker
question--
the Japanese Prime Minister, and
it were evident that the
radioactive cloud was heading
towards Tokyo, with a
population of roughly 13
million, and there was the
possibility of diverting the
cloud to the countryside, to
an area with a population
of roughly one million.
Your clicker question is this:
would it be, one, morally
mandatory to redirect the plume
from the 13 million to
the 1 million, two, morally
permitted but not morally
mandatory, or three,
morally prohibited?
So let's see how the
numbers come out.
One second remaining.
And let's see.
So 31 percent of you think it
would be morally mandatory to
redirect, 56 percent think it
would be morally permitted,
and 13 percent think it would
be morally prohibited.
Now, let me show you how you
thought about this question
when we presented it abstractly,
as a simple
trolley problem.
More than twice as many of you,
looking at these numbers,
31 percent, as opposed to 15
percent, think that it's
morally mandatory in
the actual case to
redirect the plume.
That's interesting.
It's interesting
methodologically, because it's
interesting to ask why a real
world case is giving you a
different sort of response than
a hypothetical case is.
But it's also interesting
methodologically to notice
that on the prohibition, the
numbers were almost identical.
15 percent of you thought
it was prohibited in the
imaginary case.
15 percent of you, actually 13
percent of you, thought it was
prohibited in the actual case.
So there's a way in which it
appears that these imaginary
cases are tracking, in their
abstraction, the same sort of
considerations that the actual
cases are, and ways in which
they aren't.
And I encourage you, in the
context of your sections and
your conversations amongst
yourselves, to think about why
that might be.
But in addition to being a
straight trolley problem, the
traditional Bystander case,
in the case of the nuclear
tragedy in Japan, there's also
something not very different
from what we might call
the Harm's Way case.
So you'll recall that the second
kind of case that we
thought about in the context of
trolleys concerned a case
where a trolley is hurtling
down a track towards five
individuals, and resting over
the track is a person who, if
you put him into harm's way,
could prevent the death of the
other five.
How would that go in the actual
situation that we now face?
Same nuclear accident, same
prime minister, same 13
million people, but now, as the
Prime Minister, you face
the possibility of conscripting
into certain
death a small group of
engineers, whose work on the
plant in, for example, regaining
electricity, or
pouring water in places that
would be inaccessible due to
radioactivity to anybody
whom you weren't
sending to certain death.
Individuals who are in a
position to save the lives of
these 13 million, through the
sacrifice of an incredibly
small number of individuals.
The question is this: for the
Prime Minister, supposing that
the job involves conscripting
workers to go, the plant is
about to explode and bring with
it an enormous amount of
radiation to an enormous number
of people, would it be
morally mandatory, one, morally
permitted but not
morally mandatory, or morally
prohibited to conscript the
workers, sending them
to certain death?
So the numbers here are
actually extremely
interesting, when I show them to
you in comparison with the
abstract case.
So your numbers here are 27
percent say it's prohibited,
41 percent say it's
permitted but not
prohibited, whereas only--
sorry, 41 percent say it's
permitted but not mandatory,
and only 32 percent think it
would be morally prohibited to
conscript the workers in a way
that would bring about their
certain death.
How did your numbers look
in the fat man case?
They looked very different
indeed.
Just to show you, here
were your numbers
in the actual case.
Roughly 32 percent of you
thought it was prohibited,
more than twice as many thought
it prohibited in the
case of fat man.
Now, is that because, as Josh
Greene suggests, when a
situation is up close and
personal, the way you imagine
engaging in the pushing action
somehow plays a role, as
either a legitimate or
illegitimate moral heuristic,
whereas in the case where you're
imagining conscripting
the workers, what you're doing
is somehow more distant, in
terms of the harm's way into
which you're putting it?
Is the difference that, in the
case of the workers it feels
more like a statistical harm?
And as Cass Sunstein suggests,
statistical harms are in some
ways harder for us to process?
Is what's going on in your
different response to the
Prime Minister case somehow that
the numbers 13 million
versus a small number
change the calculus?
But if they change the calculus,
then it couldn't
have been that any violable
right was driving your
response in fat man.
So for those of you who are in
the vast majority of having
moved your position--note that
mandatory went up, prohibited
went down, permitted went up--I
want you to think about
what kind of moral reasoning
explains the difference in
your response to this actual
Prime Minister case and the
imaginary Fat Man case.
And as always, these slides
will be online for you by
later today for you to
have a chance to look
closely at the numbers.
So the cases that we've been
considering so far, the cases
where earthquakes bring about
natural disasters that cause
great harm to people,
are tragedies.
But they're tragedies with
respect to which it's hard to
know where to direct our
dissatisfaction at the state
of the world.
There's very little that we can
do to prevent things like
earthquakes from happening.
And although there are
precautions that we can take
with respect to things like
nuclear power plants, again
there are features of the
world with which it's
difficult for us to
exert control.
What we moved to in the lectures
right before March
break, in the context of moral
luck, were instances where the
wrong-doing that concerned us
was perpetuated not by an
impersonal agency, like an
earthquake, but rather by an
individual.
And so we considered, for
example, the four cases of the
driver on their way
home from work.
Lucky Alert, who simply drove
home, Unlucky Alert, who drove
home alert and unfortunately hit
a child, Lucky Cell Phone,
who drove home as none of you
ever do, I'm sure, talking on
his cell phone, and Unlucky
Cell Phone, who drove home
talking on his cell phone and
tragically hit a child.
So I'm going to show you two of
your numbers from before,
and then ask you one more
clicker question.
Nearly all of you, 95 percent
of you, thought that Lucky
Alert did nothing morally
blame-worthy in driving home.
Remember, we stipulated that we
weren't talking about the
ways in which his carbon
footprint might be
contributing to various kinds of
global problems. The issue
was just whether he did
something morally wrong in
driving home, and 95 percent of
you thought that he didn't.
By contrast, 92 percent of you,
nearly everyone in the
class, thought that Unlucky Cell
Phone, the one who was
talking on his phone and hit
the child, did something
morally blame-worthy.
The question that I want to ask
you now, if you'll take
out your clickers, is whether
Unlucky Cell Phone, the person
who was talking on his phone
and hit the child, did
something that merits
punishment.
And with that, we'll move into
the central topic of our
discussion today and Thursday.
So did Unlucky Cell Phone
do something that merits
punishment in driving home and
talking on his cell phone and,
unfortunately, hitting
the child?
Let's see how our numbers
come out.
94 percent of you--
Wow, even more of you think he
deserves punishment than think
he did something wrong.
Great class!
[LAUGHTER]
What I want to do in the next
two classes is to think
seriously with you about
this rather perplexing
philosophical and psychological
phenomenon.
The fact that when somebody does
something wrong, and we
perceive the person, or we
perceive the perpetrator of
the wrongdoing, as having had
a certain sort of agency,
there is, across cultures and
across time, a tendency to
think that that individual is
deserving of punishment.
So the questions that
I want to ask in
today's lecture are three.
I want to start out by
presenting you with a classic
characterization of civil
punishment, so that we have a
sense of what it is that we're
talking about, and in so
doing, I'll present you with one
that Pojman summarized in
the outline reading that I had
you do today, that comes from
mid-1950's work in analytic
legal theory.
So I'm going to ask what it is
that we mean, when we talk
about civil or criminal
punishment.
I then want to turn to the
central philosophical question
about punishment, which is what
sort of justification
does punishment have?
And you will discover, as you
noticed already from the
readings, that two of the
dominant justifications that
are offered for punishment
actually echo two of the
dominant justifications
for moral constraint.
That is, one can give roughly
a utilitarian account of
punishment, and one can give
roughly a deontological
account of punishment.
And I want to try to get you
within the mindset of each of
those two conceptions of
punishment, both in order to
help you think about punishment
in order to help
you think about, more clearly,
some of the issues in moral
philosophy that we were talking
about before break.
And of course, I will not merely
present those views,
but will try to give you a sense
of why one might think
those are reasonable or
unreasonable justifications of
punishment.
Next class, we're going to turn
to some very interesting
psychological literature that
does, with respect to the
deontological and utilitarian
theories of punishment that
we're looking at philosophically
today, what
some of the empirical moral
literature did with respect to
deontology and utilitarianism
more generally.
That is, it suggests the
psychological substrate for
our reactions, and in some cases
tries to argue that that
renders those reactions
illegitimate.
Or illegitimate as a basis
for a certain kind
of normative judgment.
So again, I want to think about
these both as questions
about punishment, and as ways
of thinking about the
practical psychological critique
of moral theory more
generally, that we talked
about last week.
And finally, what I want to do
next class is to think about
the relation between punishment
in the civil
context and punishment in a much
more personal context.
You might have noticed that one
of the things that we're
going to be reading for Thursday
is another chapter
from I take to be the
Aristotelian-inspired
parenting guide of
Alan Kazdin.
So let me offer one caveat,
which is the topic of
punishment is enormous.
We could offer an
entire lecture
course on this question.
And what I'm presenting to you
in the class is a pretty
bread-and-butter Anglo-American
picture of what
punishment amounts to.
Any of you who have thought
about punishment in the
context of social theory have
encountered some of the
sophisticated critiques of
punishment that come to the
Western twentieth-century
philosophical tradition
largely through the writing
of Nietzsche and Foucault.
And simply due to time
constraints, not because these
are uninteresting, indeed
they are extraordinarily
interesting, we won't be
thinking about these writers
in this class.
Though, as always, I'm very
happy during office hours or
other times to talk to
you about those.
So let's start with the first
of these questions.
What do we mean by
civil punishment?
So when you clicked on your
clicker and you said that
Unlucky Cell Phone, the man who
talking on his cell phone
accidentally killed the child,
when you said that Unlucky
Cell Phone was someone who
merited punishment, presumably
you were thinking of something
with roughly the five
characteristics that are taken
to be characteristics of
paradigmatic instances of
punishment, are perhaps even
as necessary and sufficient
conditions for what it is for
something to be punishment.
So the first thing, the first
characteristic, the one
perhaps most salient when we
think about punishment, is
that punishment is something
that involves a certain kind
of unpleasantness
or suffering.
In traditional culture,
punishment involved either the
infliction of some sort of
physical pain, or the
social isolation, or the
infliction of some sort
of public humiliation.
All of these involved
unpleasantness and suffering.
In the amazing description of
the three horses from Plato's
Phaedrus that we read at the
beginning of the semester, the
charioteer, in his effort to
direct the recalcitrant wild
horse, pulls on the bit in a way
that brings blood to the
mouth of the horse in an effort
to inflict punishment.
So the core notion is that
punishment involves
unpleasantness and suffering.
It involves bringing somebody
into a state that brings
disutility to them.
As far as the felicific calculus
goes, the calculus of
felicity, the enumeration of the
amount of happiness in the
world, punishment reduces in
that individual the amount of
happiness that they have.
Second characteristic.
Punishment is not merely the
infliction of pain or
suffering on an individual.
It's the infliction of pain or
suffering on an individual in
response to a particular
offense.
Either a legal offense, in the
case of legal punishment.
Or if you think that punishment
is also something
that can be carried out with
regard to moral trespasses, in
response to a moral offense.
So it's not just a bringing
about of pain
randomly in the world.
It's a bringing about of pain in
the world in response to a
legal offense.
To the person who committed
the offense.
So, it's not merely that if
something bad happens in a
location: you find an
individual and visit
suffering upon them.
The individual on whom suffering
is visited is
supposed to be the one who has
been judged, by whatever
procedures are considered the
legitimate procedures for
making such judgments, to
have been an offender.
Moreover, the punishment needs
to be intentionally
administered by a human agent.
It's not enough if natural
forces somehow bring about the
bad consequences.
And we'll talk about that, with
respect to a puzzle, in
the case of retributive
punishment, in a moment.
And finally, it's imposed and
administered not by an
individual acting on his or her
own, or even by a posse of
individuals, who have taken the
law into their hands, but
rather by a legal authority that
has the sanction of the
state or civil institution
behind it.
So the question that punishment
raises, and we'll
think about this again when we
start thinking about political
theory more generally, is how is
it that a state could ever
be justified in bringing harm
to one of its members.
How could it be legitimate for
a society to cause one of its
individuals to experience
unpleasantness or suffering?
So there are two basic kinds
of justification that are
offered for punishment.
The first is a forward-looking
justification.
It's one that says punishment is
an effective mechanism for
avoiding future harm.
When somebody acts in a way that
violates either legal or
social norm, that individual
indicates, perhaps, a
likelihood of acting
in that way again.
And so disabling them
is important.
Or, when an individual acts in
a way that violates legal or
social norms, and others see
that the individual has acted
in that way, and received no
negative consequences from the
community as a result,
others will be likely
to act in that way.
And so punishment serves a
public deterrent function.
Regardless of how it's
operationalized, and we'll
talk a bit more about that at
the end of the lecture, the
basic motivation for the
forward-looking justification
of punishment is that punishment
is an effective
means of avoiding future harm.
So that in some way, the
suffering of the individual
who is punished on behalf of
the state is offset by the
benefits to other individuals
that will result as a
consequence of having caused
suffering in one place.
It's a trade-off of disutility
and utility.
The second sort of justification
of punishment,
and let me say, those of you who
felt unsatisfied by number
one but frustrated by Kant in
our moral theory discussion
before March break, have some
thinking to do about how your
worldviews fit together.
The second justification of
punishment is that punishment
is called for, because when
somebody violates moral or
legal codes, they deserve
to be penalized.
The justification is not that
it's a way of avoiding future
harm, though it might happen to
bring that, as a nice added
of benefit.
The reason an individual is to
be punished on this picture is
because in committing a moral or
legal violation, the person
has violated the moral or legal
code in such a way that
what he or she deserves
is to be punished.
So those are the two
justifications that we're
going to think about.
But I want to point out that
there's another way of
thinking about punishment that
we'll talk about a little bit
more in the context of the
lecture, which is, you might
think about punishment as
being a response to a
disruption of the social order,
in such a way that at
least two individuals
are involved.
One, the victim, with respect
to whom, if you want to
restore the pre-harm state, the
important thing to think
about in the context of
punishment is neither the
large question about retribution
nor the large
question about deterrence,
though those are important to
the individual as a member of
society, but rather in the
case of this specific crime,
what one wants to think about
is restitution.
What can be done to restore
the individual to
her pre-harm state?
And, in the case of the
offender, one might think
about what can be done to
restore that individual to
what one might think of as a
larger, more global pre-harm
state, namely towards a
situation of pro-sociality.
So let's illustrate these
four ideas with
a particular example.
Here's our old friend Gyges,
remember him, back in January?
There he was, and for now,
we've given him a horse.
So Gyges has a horse, and up
shows Pedro, he's our bad guy
from Jim and the Indians,
and Pedro goes and
steals Gyges' horse.
Now, what is to be done?
Well, if the question that
interests us is that of
restoring the situation to its
pre-harm state, then our
primary concern is
with restitution.
We want Pedro to give Gyges
back his horse.
Suppose that instead of stealing
Gyges' horse, Pedro
had murdered Gyges' horse?
We might think then that what
restitution requires is
presenting Pedro with something
as good as the horse
he previously had.
Perhaps Pedro needs to give dot
Gyges one of his horses.
But the picture that lies behind
restitution, and we'll
talk about the ways in which
restitution is problematic,
when restoring to the pre-harm
state involves something a
little more complicated than
giving back stolen property or
replacing in kind.
The notion behind restitution is
that the goal in which the
state has legitimate reason to
be engaged, is that of taking
the innocent party and making
sure that they are no worse
off after having suffered
a crime than
before having suffered.
What does the notion of
rehabilitation tell us to do
in this state?
Well, presumably it tells us to
think about how-- there's
Pedro with a shepherd's
staff--
how can we help make somebody,
whose interactions with
society involve violations of
its norms, such that he or she
comes to internalize those
norms in a way that they
become the grounding for
his or her behavior?
In some ways, rehabilitation is
the most effective means of
deterrence and prevention.
If it's possible to reinstate
pro-sociality in parts of the
individuals towards whom we are
expressing concern through
punishment, wouldn't that be
the most effective means?
So that's one version
of thinking about
what's going on.
We might think about restitution
for the harmed and
rehabilitation for the harmer.
Alternatively, we might think
about the question in terms of
the two categories that we're
going to focus on for the
remainder of lecture.
That is, we might lock up
Pedro and do so with the
justification that that
will prevent him from
doing future crime.
Or we might lock up Pedro with
the thought-- watch the slide,
it's the only joke all lecture--
that in so doing,
what we provide is justice.
There's one more visual joke
later in lecture about the
ways in which it is part of
our pop culture, part of
cartoons, part of comic books,
part of movies, that somehow
the visiting of justice upon
an offender is absolutely
critical to society's
well-being.
So what I want to do is
introduce you now, from the
inside, from the work of Kant,
on the one hand, and then more
generally, and then through
the work of Rawls on the
other, to these two sorts
of justifications.
So let's start with the
retributivist outlook.
That's the outlook, roughly,
that when somebody does
something that violates legal
or moral norms, they've
committed a wrong, and in so
doing they've put the scales
of justice somehow
out of line.
And that what punishment does is
it reorients the scales of
justice, it re-balances
things.
In punishing the harm-doer, we
reorient the world in such a
way that injustice becomes
re-weighted, that desert is
visited upon the harm-doer.
So the text we read in
discussing the retributivist
outlook was that of
Immanuel Kant.
And Kant writes explicitly
"juridical punishment can
never be administered merely
as a means for promoting
another good, either with regard
to the criminal himself
or the civil society." That is,
deterrence, prevention of
future harm, rehabilitation,
all of --
those are other goods--
may well come along in the
wake of punishment.
But that cannot be the
justification for the action.
"Judicial punishment," says
Kant, "can be imposed only
because the individual on whom
it is inflicted has committed
a crime." This is of
a piece with Kant's
more general outlook.
You recall from the opening
pages of the Groundwork that
Kant isn't interested in
thinking about consequences.
Kant is interested in thinking
about moral rightness, and the
way in which our behaviors and
our social institutions can
reflect our recognition
of this fundamental
fact about the world.
So those of you who are drawn to
the picture that criminals
deserve their deserts, not for
utilitarian reasons but for
fundamental ones, need to
think about whether that
brings in its wake for you a
commitment to something like
the more general Kantian
outlook, whereby a good will
is good not because of what it
affects or accomplishes, but
rather good in itself.
That's the core of the
retributivist outlook.
The retributivist outlook
often brings with it--
in addition to an answer to
the question, what's the
justification for punishment?
Answer, moral desert--an account
of what Kant, in the
writings that we read for today,
calls the "principle
and standards of public
justice." That is,
retributivism includes not
merely the idea that criminals
deserve penalty, but also a
picture of what grounds that
penalty, and sometimes a
characterization of what those
specific penalties amount to.
So Kant writes, "the undeserved
evil which anyone
commits to another is to be one
regarded as perpetrated on
himself." That is, a principled
justification for
punishment in kind to the harm
one has committed underlies
Kant's picture.
So, he continues, "whoever
steals makes
all property insecure.
He therefore robs himself
of security in property,
according to the right of
retaliation." The punishment
for theft is loss of property,
says Kant, on the principle
that the undeserved evil which
anyone commits on another is
to be regarded as perpetrated
on himself.
The logic of that argument, of
course, brings with it the
conclusion that Pojman helpfully
italicizes in Kant
for us, "whoever has committed
murder must die." I'm not sure
the italics are in the original
German, but they do
serve to make the text
effective, for those of you
coming back from March break and
looking for a wake-up call
in doing your reading.
So the picture that retaliation
of the sort that
is demanded by moral desert,
that retribution for harm
brings with it the mandate
that a similar harm be
perpetrated on you has, in
Kant's articulation, a
particular form.
The thought that death should
be visited upon one who
commits a crime of killing has
struck many as a way of
expressing not retribution,
but revenge.
And I want to present you with a
very nice analysis, that was
adverted to in one of your
readings, that Robert Nozick,
whom we'll be reading
more from later and
read some from before.
A nice analysis that he offers
of the difference between
retribution, on the one hand,
and revenge, on the other.
Because I want to try to give
you a really clean picture of
what the retributionist
picture amounts to.
So one axis along which you
might contrast retribution and
revenge is what it is that
triggers a desire for
retribution.
And Nozick says retribution is
triggered by a legal or moral
wrong, a violation of a code
that is accepted by all
parties, though it may have been
violated by one of them,
whereas revenge might occur
in response to a harm or a
slight, not a violation of
the moral code, as such.
There are, says Nozick,
limits to retribution.
Kant has just articulated
one version of that.
We penalize exactly in
proportion to the harm done,
on Kant's picture.
By contract, revenge is, in
principle, unlimited.
In terms of the personality
involved, the degree of
personalization, retribution
is impersonal, it's carried
out by the state.
Remember, that was one of our
characterizations, one of the
elements of our characterization
of
punishment.
Whereas revenge is personal.
It's carried out by an
individual for the sake of
expressing that individual's
dissatisfaction.
Retribution differs from revenge
in emotional tone.
When one engages in retribution,
one either takes
pleasure in justice itself, or
has no emotional feeling.
When you put a criminal in
jail, the pleasure is in
having done the right thing, as
far as justice demands, not
the pleasure in seeing the
suffering of another.
There's a kind of generality
that attaches to retribution.
An individual who performs a
particular kind of act in a
particular kind of circumstance,
whoever they
are, is going to be worthy
of retribution.
Whereas in the case of revenge,
it's about a specific
person at a specific time, not
as an instance of a category,
but as a particular wrongdoer
in eyes of
the one taking vengeance.
There is a way in which
retribution and revenge are
similar, and that is that both
of them are expressive acts.
In the case of both of them, the
target is supposed to know
why the penalty is being
inflicted, and to know that he
is intended to know that.
So again, these slides will be
up, if you didn't get down all
the details.
But the picture of retribution
that we're interested in is
the one on the left.
So, I want to talk about two
cases where this knowledge
condition gives rise to
potentially amusing or
perplexing situations.
One, in the case of revenge, and
the other in the case of
retribution.
So it is, as you know, a trope
in comic books that the
villain is always trying to kill
the hero in such a way
that the hero knows why the
villain is trying to do that.
And those of you familiar with
Austin Powers know that Austin
Powers is always able to escape
Dr. Evil, because Dr.
Evil is so concerned with what
we might think about the
publicity constraint or the
expressive role of revenge.
But in addition to creating plot
lines in parody movies,
the phenomenon that retribution
involves a
particular kind of bringing
about of harm gives rise to a
perplexing phenomenon, that we
might call "justice as the
world ends."
So Nozick writes, "the
conditions demarcating
retribution explain what
otherwise appears to be a
ludicrous phenomenon.
If someone sentenced to death
falls perilously ill or
attempts suicide, execution is
postponed and measures are
taken to bring the condemned
person back to health, so that
he can then be executed.
This is because his punishment
is to involve something being
visited upon him by others
because of the
wrongness of his act.
His death by natural causes or
by his own hand would avoid
this so measures are taken to
restore him for punishment."
Notice the way in which this
parallels the discussion of
the drowning child case in the
work of Mill's Utilitarianism,
on the one hand, Kant's
Groundwork, on the other.
Mill is just interested in the
child getting out of the pond,
and isn't, in that passage,
interested in whether you do
it because you're showing off
for somebody that you want to
impress on the shoreline, or
trying to get a financial
reward, or expressing a
certain kind of moral
commitment.
Kant is interested in why
you are doing it.
So too here.
The retributivist picture says
what matters is not that the
criminal end up dead, at the
end of things, in some way.
What matter is that the criminal
end up dead or
punished in the right kind of
way, at the end of things,
because of a particular
process.
So we'll close today's lecture
and continue with
utilitarianism next class with
the otherwise perplexing quote
from the end of Kant, which you
are now in a position to
understand.
Kant writes, if it's 2012, and
the world is ending, in the
way that it does in that movie,
and the waves are
coming in and the lightning is
striking, and the new Ice Age
is emerging, the first thing
you have to do before the
world ends, says Kant,
is execute
everybody on death row.
"Even if civil society resolves
to dissolve itself,
the last murderer lying in
prison," says Kant, "ought to
be executed before it does.
This ought to be done."--this is
the retributivist picture--
"that everyone may realize
the desert of his deeds."
We'll pick up again on Thursday,
with the utilitarian
justification for punishment.
And I'll see you then.